a lot of people say that's the best
shining did you meet Stephen King while
filming now I know you did a bunch of
stuff with Stephen King he was around a
lot during the filming of The Shining
and I was able to ask him questions
because I was reading the book while
doing it there was a portion of the book
that I I couldn't understand it was like
a little triplet or something like that
and I asked him what it meant and I
thought oh great I've got a living
author downstairs what does this mean
Steve and basically he was like yeah
this line um is about a bottle of wine
this is because I was standing over a
carpet and it had a color that intrigued
me and this I was drunk
and I was like oh thanks Steve I was
hoping for something a little more
profound really deep no he was a great
guy he's fantastic